[00:27:06] So we've gotten to the point where
any attempts to do actual journalism and hold
people in positions of power accountable is
going to be written off as an attack by a
huge portion of Americans, because that is
exactly what their fearless orange leader
Donald Trump is doing.
Donald Trump was asked by reporter you meet
Shay Alcindor during his Corona virus emergency
declaration on Friday about how he shut down
the pandemic response team.
Trump called the question nasty claim to have
no idea what she was talking about.
But but also sort of blamed Anthony Foushee,
who is standing behind him, who just said,
I don't know anything about it.
This is just disgusting and stunning.
And watch Trump say, well, I don't know.
That's a nasty question.
Maybe ask Anthony Foushee.
I have no idea.
[00:27:53][46.6]
[00:27:54] My first question is, you said
that you don't take responsibility, but you
did disband the White House pandemic office.
And the officials that were working in that
office left this administration abruptly.
So what responsibility do you take to that?
And the officials that worked in that office
said that you that the White House lost valuable
time because that office wasn't disbanded.
What do you make of that?
[00:28:14][19.1]
[00:28:15] Well, I just think it's a nasty
question, because what we've done is and Tony
has said numerous times that we've saved thousands
of lives because of the quick closing.
And when you say me, I didn't do it.
We have a group of people I could I could
ask.
Perhaps it may have been stranger.
But I could perhaps ask.
Tony, about that, because I don't know anything
about it.
I mean, you say you say we did that.
I don't know anything about it.
You don't know spending reorganization that
happened in the National Cancer Administration.
Perhaps they do that.
You know, people let people go.
He used to be with a different newspaper than
you are now.
You know, things like that happen, but this
isn't always.
Go ahead.
We're doing a great job.
[00:28:52][37.1]
[00:28:53] Noticed Trump slipping in there.
Will you change jobs?
So like maybe the pandemic response, people
also just changed jobs.
Nothing to see here denying it happened, but
saying if it did happen, maybe Anthony Foushee
know something about it.
Now, there's something special that I have
for you today on this.
Back in 2018, Trump was asked why did you
cut the pandemic response team?
And at the time, Trump knew exactly what he
was being asked about.
And he didn't deny doing it.
And in fact, he defended what he did.
He said, hey, we haven't used those people
and I don't want to pay people that we aren't
using.
Remember Trump three days ago saying pandemic
response?
That's nasty.
Maybe ask Foushee.
Here is Trump right after he did it, saying,
oh, yeah, I did it.
And here's why.
[00:29:38][45.1]
[00:29:39] Some of the people we can't they
haven't been used for many, many years.
And if they if we ever need it, we can get
it very quickly.
[00:29:45][6.1]
[00:29:46] And rather than spending the money
and I'm a business person, I don't like having
thousands of people around when you don't
need it.
[00:29:51][5.7]
[00:29:52] So Friday it's I didn't cut anyone.
That's a nasty question.
If anybody did get cut, maybe Foushee did
it.
I don't know when he did talk about it.
Back in twenty eighteen, he knew exactly what
he had done.
He defended doing it.
But the real thing here is, listen, Trump
being a liar and Trump being incompetent,
that's not new.
The treatment of journalism, as is what it
is actually nasty here.
Calling journalism nasty is very, very nasty.
Donald Trump has framed up a situation where
as far as he's concerned, he's done everything
right and Obama everything wrong.
Questioning him about it is nasty, asking
questions like you did this and it didn't
work out well.
Are you responsible?
That's a gotcha question.
In this era and of course, there's always
the question, is he more likely to refer to
women as nasty?
Is he more likely to be referring to black
women as nasty as is the case in this particular
instance?
I don't know.
We'd have to run the numbers on that.
One never knows.
But what's nasty is Trump's behavior, his
competence, which is incompetence, his treatment
of others, others, and absolutely and totally
weaponising delusional narcissism, weaponised
delusional narcissism maybe should be the
tagline of this administration.
[00:31:14][81.9]
[241.7]